bonjour bienvenue sur les chaînes
parlementaires c'est parlement hebdo
avec aude moracchini bonjour toute
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
résumé en 45 minutes et l'actualité
cette semaine et dominer encore une fois
par l'europe et la crise de l'euro alors
que les agences de notation menacent de
dégrader tous les pays de l'union
l'allemagne et la france proposent un
nouveau pacte plus de discipline
budgétaire
la semaine a commencé à 2 elle se
termine par l'accord avec 17 pays de la
zone euro et les autres pays volontaires
sont les bienvenus autoriser le droit de
vote des étrangers aux élections locales
le sénat majoritaire à gauche a voté
pour cette proposition de loi socialiste
ambiance électrique dans l'hémicycle le
premier ministre est venu en personne
défendre la position du gouvernement
à l'extérieur deux manifestations les
antilles menée par le front national est
l'époux avec notamment eva joly le récit
de cette journée
dans un instant enfin une pièce de
théâtre soulève les passions chez
certains catholiques golgota picnic qui
est jouée en ce moment à paris créé la
polémique
une lecture provoquant des évangiles une
tête de crucifixion jugé blasphématoire
mobilisation manifestation de la
communauté catholique
une veillée a même été organisé en
l'église notre dame à paris est avec
nous pour commenter l'actualité
christine boutin bonjour merci d'être
avec nous sur ce plateau vous êtes
présidente du parti chrétien démocrate
candidate à l'élection présidentielle
comme en 2100 2002 voilà vous avez
obtenu 1,2 pour cent des suffrages un
score qui vous a pas découragé vous a
été l'une des premières dans les
starting blocks
cette année et vous avez présenté votre
programme cette semaine on y reviendra
première question vous avez annoncé que
vous n'aviez que pour l'instant que 150
parrainage il en faut 500 d'ici le mois
de mars
est-ce que c'est mal parti pour vous
écouter oui c'est mal parti
et
et je suis absolument stupéfaite de
constater vous savez quand je parle
c'est parce que je sais je ne fais pas
de procès d'intention
je ne pouvais pas imaginer qu'il y ait
un blocage qu'il ya un blocage
en ce qui concerne ses parrainages or
aujourd'hui je peux confirmer que
monsieur copé a donné l'ordre à ses
cadres à l'ump que les parrainages ne
soit donnée au seul candidat de l'ump si
bien que ça naturellement des
conséquences très importantes en
particulier dans les intercommunalités
puisque les maires divers droite sont
naturellement très inquiet de l'avenir
de de leurs ronds points et c'est leur
subvention mais deuxièmement et j'ai
appris ça hier à l'élysée on bloque
également les signatures d'options
entend bien ça vient d'une part de l'ump
d'autre part de l'elysée affirmant qu
est ce que vous allez faire
eh bien écoutez je vais me battre je
vais me battre pour obtenir ces
signatures
je n'ai pas dû faire appel au conseil
d'état ah ben ça y est c'est en cours là
ça s'est fait en cours on est en train
de faire le joli nous allons l'ump et
l'elysée de faire blocage contre vous
absolument c'est à dire c'est un blocage
de la démocratie absolument et j'irai
jusqu'au bout
vous m'entendez j'irai jusqu'au bout
parce que là c'est même pas mes idées
que je défends c'est la démocratie
alors j'ai jusqu'à la fin février pour
obtenir ces signatures ces parrainages
on verra à ce moment là mais je peux
vous dire que je débloquerait la bombe
atomique
je suis en guerre qu'est ce que ça veut
dire vous mener une guerre la bombe
atomique ça veut dire jusqu'à les bains
vous verrez vous verrez au moment où
vous verrez au moment où je prendrai la
décision si elle est nécessaire parce
que c'est inadmissible c'est scandaleux
je ne pouvais même pas imaginer qu'en
france une république démocratique qui
donne des leçons au monde qui est pays
des droits de l'homme on puisse en vain
ainsi assumé de kidnapper de cadenasser
la démocratie mais on sait même pas pour
moi je dis c'est au delà de cela c'est
quelque chose qui le révolte mais
profondément un goûter on aimerait
comprendre c'est quoi cette bombe
atomique à part saisir le conseil d'état
y vivent tuellement
construite visionnaire imaginez vous
aviez proposé à la nuit de soutenir
nicolas sarkozy
si jamais vous n'étiez pas au deuxième
tour vous avez dit clairement que vous
étiez une candidate de premier tour vous
pourriez du coup ne pas soutenir nicolas
sarkozy mais on verra jeunes venus tout
est permis aujourd'hui dirai rien de
plus aujourd'hui mais ce que je peux
vous dire j'espère que ça passe bien
auprès de vos téléspectateurs
ça sera diffusée au canal détermination
absolue à défendre la démocratie qui
aujourd'hui je le dis est en danger et
ça c'est inacceptable dit calida ou pour
rien que les uns à voter pour un autre
candidat je ne vous dirai rien de plus
mais la démocratie cadenassé en france
jamais je ne l'accepterai jamais votre
question concernant votre candidature
vous avez dit que s'il y avait une
menace fn possibilité que le front
national soit au deuxième tour vous vous
retiriez peut-être plus vite que prévu
est ce qu'aujourd'hui le front national
qui sera autour de 17 %
est ce que c'est une menace déjà très
hot pot non je crois que c'est pas c'est
pas une menace a dit c'est juste que
c'est pourtant c'est parce que c'est pas
une menace
on verra on verra mais de toute façon
moi je dois dire qu'avec les
informations que j'ai depuis dix jours
les cartes sont rebattues ans qui me
dire c'est tout jusqu'à une dernière
question qui ne pas vous faire plaisir
ce que c'est pas normal finalement que
l'ump appelle ses élus à voter pour son
parti
je non parce que le parrainage est un
n'est pas un soutien des idées il est un
soutien à la démocratie et donc le fait
de donner des ordres et même d'aller
plus loin je n'irai pas plus loin parce
que je vois là mais les plus loin des
moutons si vous condamnez aujourd'hui
pourquoi ne pas carrément mais l'écart
sur les propos qui ont été tenus sont
inacceptables par rapport à la
démocratie de l'ump
l'ump que l'ump
ayant envie d'avoir un seul candidat je
le sais bien le président de la
république depuis toujours qu'il ne veut
pas d'autre candidat je le comprends
bien mais
le président de la république n'est pas
propriétaire des voix de chacun des élus
de france et la démocratie n'a pas à
subir des pressions c'est tout mais moi
j'affirme que aujourd'hui et la
démocratie est en danger
donc j'en appelle et vous verrez vous
verrez je je suis déterminé mais alors
là vraiment déterminé parce que je ne
pouvais pas imaginer je ne pouvais pas
imaginer qu'en france il puisse y avoir
une telle attitude bien on voulait pas
en dire plus
pourtant c'est dommage vous vous le
disiez là pour pour vous exprimer
justement sursis on attendra on attendra
évidemment que vous voulez bien on
dirait un petit peu plus on va passer à
l'actualité de la semaine et lundi le
couple nicolas sarkozy angela merkel ne
se lâchent plus nouvelle conférence de
presse commune mais cette fois à paris à
l'invitation de nicolas sarkozy l'accord
qui s'est dessiné entre paris et berlin
met en avant une europe à la stricte
discipline budgétaire l'enjeu est de
taille
restaurer la confiance dans la zone euro
il est vrai qu'il ya urgence kathia
gilder et l'ime rencontre du couple
franco-allemand à l'elysée pour sauver
la zone euro
mais cette fois le président français et
la chancelière allemande veulent aller
très vite en première ligne dans le
règlement de la crise nicolas sarkozy et
angela merkel ont plaidé d'une seule
voix pour un nouveau traité européen
notre préférence va vers un traité à 27
donc personne ne se sente exclu de la
démarche franco-allemande mais nous
sommes tout à fait prêts à passer par un
traité à 10 est ouvert à tous les états
qui voudraient nous rejoindre ce nouveau
traité sera fondée sur une règle d'or
l'inscription de l' équilibre budgétaire
dans la constitution de chaque pays
européen des sanctions automatiques
seront prévues contre les états membres
qui dépasseront le déficit autorisé il
nous faut les récoltes
ayant tu définis harmonisés et non la
kora magicien le sort aux élèves
vérifier la condition pour que tous les
simplement s'engager à respecter
seule concession faite à la france ce
sont les cours constitutionnelles
nationales et non la cour de justice
européenne qui vérifieront que la règle
d'or est bien respectée les deux
dirigeants ont par ailleurs fermement
rejeté le recours à des euro-obligations
l'allemagne refusant toute mutualisation
de la dette européenne
alors christine boutin la discipline
budgétaire c'est la seule façon d'y
arriver de sauver l'europe
j'ai voté contre maastricht
comme j'étais parlementaire non pas
parce que je ne suis pas européenne bien
au contraire car je m'inscris dans la
filiation de robert schuman je crois
dans l'europe et il faut sauver l'europe
j'ai voté contre maastricht en 1992
parce que je pensais que le traité
portait en lui même les difficultés
auxquelles nous sommes confrontés
aujourd'hui je ne crois absolument pas
et ce n'est pas en raison de ma colère
que je vient d'exprimer
je ne crois absolument pas
malheureusement à aux accords tels
qu'ils sont prévus pour l'instant le
nouveau traité par exemple ça ne passera
pas ne pense pas c'est encore un comment
dirais-je une action pour essayer
d'éviter la réalité on ne pourra pas
construire l'europe
si les peuples ne sont pas partant or
aujourd'hui les peuples ne sont pas
partant cet accord je comprends bien
compte tenu de l'urgence est quelque
chose qui va être imposé cet accord ce
traité est fondée uniquement sur des
problèmes financiers
moi je me pose énormément de questions
énormément de questions comment se
fait-il
comment se fait-il qu'en grèce on a qu
on a interdit le référendum qui étaient
demandées par le peuple
en italie on a souhaité on a fait une
espèce de coup d'état moi je soutiens
pop bernasconi mais enfin c'est un
espèce de coup d'état qui s'est passé
la bce vous avez un dirigeant les trois
dirigeants grèce italie bce viennent de
la goldman sachs goldman sachs
qui elle-même a été un des instruments
des difficultés financières dans lequel
nous trouvons plan mondial
je me demande vraiment si nous sommes
sortis de l'autorité financière et
économique
et si en réalité le politique fait les
utilités ne fait pas les utilités 1,7 à
face sont les critiques parce qu'on a un
petit peu à vos propositions vous
proposer la création d'un euro franc de
quoi s'agit-il exactement alors si vous
voulez je pense qu'effectivement il faut
sauver l'euro est aujourd'hui dans
l'urgence il faut que le politique
reprenne la main et nous pouvons nous
sur nos territoires nationaux reprendre
la main le politique peut donner des
ordres à la banque de france pour créer
une monnaie
ce sont les monnaies complémentaires ces
monnaies complémentaires elles sont
fondées sur le fait qu'elle crée du
pouvoir d'achat parce que la vitesse de
rotation pourquoi elle elle servirait
pour la conservation grande bo course
votre réfrigérateur votre et qu'on place
pas s'appelle offrant par exemple leur
offrant mais qui circulent a
parallèlement à l'euro oui mais qui est
uniquement enfin uniquement sur notre
territoire un peu une planche à billets
non mais arrêtez arrêtez l'inflation moi
vous êtes plus jeune que moi mais moi ma
génération l'inflation moi si j'ai pu
payer ma maison c'est grâce à
l'inflation
aujourd'hui on est tous en train de
mourir la bouche ouverte
parce qu'il faut pas d'inflation enfin
arrêtons donc de retour retour avait une
forme d'inflation jeu
je propose un retour à ce que le
politique prenne ses responsabilités la
bce quand j'étais parlementaire je n'ai
pas voté l'indépendance de la bce
pourquoi est ce que les politiques ont
abandonné tout le pouvoir ils ont laissé
la main entre tous les financiers et
aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression que rien
n'est véritablement changé il y a des
gens qui se suicident aujourd'hui dans
notre pays parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
finir leurs fins de mois
or quand on regarde la réalité
financière ce n'est qu'une simple
écriture
il suffit de l'effacer pour que cette
personne retrouve son équilibre alors
nous restons là fait quoi servez vous
vous proposez aussi la création d'un
revenu de base 500 euros par mois pour
tout le monde quel que soit le revenu
oui alors c'est pas un peu inégalitaire
non pas du tout aux sites non pas du
tout c'est une
c'est un le revenu de base est une
véritable réforme de révolution même je
dirais dans le partage de la richesse
on ne peut pas continuer comme on est
aujourd'hui le revenu de base c'est la
simplification
c'est la reconnaissance de chacun c'est
une équité alors parce que tu existes de
la naissance à la mort tu as droit à un
revenu de base qui est de 200 euros
jusqu'à 18 ans et 400 euros jusqu'à la
fin de sa structure et à tout le reste
sauf sauf le chômage souffre la retraite
sauf la santé sauf le handicap sur le
congé parental sinon toutes les autres
prestations sur dans le pot commun
donc ça ne coûte pas un centime de plus
a été calculée à budget constant
en contrepartie je crée un service
national qui est pour les garçons et
pour les filles d'une durée d'un an
entre 18 et et la fin des études
je vois que vous êtes impatients donc je
m'attends pas du tout ça ce sont vos
propositions mais je voulais revenir
d'un mot sur sur le roc de ce que de ce
couple franco allemand
vous pensez qu'on a trop cédé à
l'allemagne je pense que la situation du
président de la république n'est pas
facile parce que la france n'est
malheureusement pas une position facile
je pense que la main l'allemagne va être
obligé aussi de comprendre qu' il faut à
falloir qu'elles fassent des efforts
aussi parce que son marché c'est quand
même marché européen je trouve que les
allemands sont un peu aveuglé par
rapport à cette réalité économique alors
justement cette semaine encore flotte la
polémique après les propos jugés
germanophobe de responsables socialistes
la double réponse en ce lundi nicolas
sarkozy qui en appelle à la
responsabilité collective et françois
hollande en voyage à berlin on les
écoute
la gauche a toujours cru à l'amitié
franco allemand la droite aussi et je
souhaite que quel que soit le calendrier
électoral
chacun sache le hisser à la hauteur de
sa responsabilité
il ne pas jouer avec l'histoire de nos
deux pays
le tout selon lui dans l'égalité et dans
le respect non pas l'imitation dans la
combine abonnés mais la connaissance de
l'univers
je me comprend l'allemand et vous au
choc et les propos du parti socialiste
on a parlé d' arnaud montebourg de jean
marie le guen qui parle de résurgence du
nationalisme allemand oui moi il m'a
choqué parce qu'ils sont dans une
période où naturellement tout prend
beaucoup plus déclare par rapport à
l'allemagne et mais ils ne sont pas les
seuls à avoir eu des propos un peu dur
il ya quelques années ça n'avait pas eu
du tout le même écho je crois
qu'effectivement il faut faire très
attention mais moi ce que je dirais de
cela c'est que plus en réalité il faut
quand même que nous fassions attention
bien sûr l'europe ne peut être
construite qu'avec les français et les
allemands sur la base de ce couple mais
il faut faire attention aussi à ce que
ce couple n'écrase pas les autres pays
et vous pensez qu'en ce moment c'est ce
qu'il est en train de se passer en ce
moment je pense qu'il ya un certain
nombre d'interrogations comment se
fait-il que la hongrie n'est pas signé
l'accord
les anglais n'ont pu voir mais les
anglais classique et les anglais sont
prêts vous savez dans la ferme moi
personnellement je suis absolument
convaincu que nous sommes rentrés dans
une guerre économique une guerre entre
les etats-unis et l europe sur le plan b
c'est un problème de monnaie entre le
dollar et l'euro donc que les anglais
soient pas dans cette affaire ça me
semble assez normal mêlant la hongrie on
en parle peu mais enfin comment se
fait-il que la hongrie moi je ne sais
pas mais ça m'interroge et je pense
qu'il faut que nous fassions très
attention je vous disais tout à l'heure
l'europe se construira avec l'adhésion
des peuples eh bien il faut que la
france et l'allemagne n'est pas une
attitude de domination vis-à-vis des
autres pays
il ya quand même 23 ce jour qui ont
suivi selon lui alors vous ré maintenant
vous faire réagir
à une image posez peut-être déjà vu ça
se passe en italie ce lundi l'italie qui
présente un plan de rigueur drastique la
ministre des affaires sociales est en
train de présenter la réforme des
retraites un domaine dans lequel elle
est experte et au moment de prononcer le
mot de sacrifices elle craque sous
l'oeil du nouveau premier ministre mario
monti on regarde l aurais bien beau de
route et que cela nous a coûté
psychologiquement
puis nous avons dû demander un sacré je
pense qu'elle voulait dire des
sacrifices alors c'est une scène
étonnante 1,7 à l'intrusion de la
sensibilité de l'empathie et d'un
ministre pour pour des gens qui vont
devoir faire des sacrifices
ça vous inspire quoi bien je pense que
cette fin que je ne connais pas connaît
parfaitement la réalité de la vie de ses
concitoyens parce qu'on peut se dire une
si mon dieu la pauvre elle et elle et
elle est trop faible pour ce monde là
non non non non ça c'est pas non non non
non la politique c'est un monde très dur
ce monde de violence etc
mais cette femme pour moi du reste qui
n'est pas je crois pas elle n'a pas une
carrière politique très anciennes je ne
crois pas voilà elle est experte en
matière économique et elle connaît la
réalité de la vie de ses concitoyens et
elle sait très bien comme experte
quelles vont être les conséquences sur
la vie quotidienne de ses concitoyens et
ls montrer son nez son son émotion
et bien moi voyez bien écouté mais vous
avez vous-même montrer votre émotion 98
euros du pacs se rappelle aussi heures
de vol à rien madame royal aussi qu'il
ne devienne pas trop cela sert aux
politiques ou dessert je vais le jeu
recul honnêtement je pense qu'aucune des
trois femmes ne l'a fait pour servir ou
pas servir c'est on a craqué on a montré
qu'on n'était pas des marionnettes ont
été ouverts d'été de chair et d'os et
qui a parfois l'armure qui craque
il n'y a pas de honte à ça pas dans
l'intérêt de l'humanité vous savez
aujourd'hui dans ce monde de brutes
je crois que c'est pas mal le président
du conseil italien mario monti qui
renonce à ses salaires double salaire de
président du conseil des min
de l'économiste une bonne formule oui
c'est bien ça sauvera pas l'italie elle
sait bien
symboliquement c'est important
d'apporter un la symbolique allez on
continue le déroulé de la semaine mardi
l'assemblée nationale se penche sur le
problème de la prostitution
les députés ont adopté à l'unanimité une
proposition de résolution elle réaffirme
la position abolitionniste de la france
en matière de prostitution premier pas
vers un possible pénalisation des
clients
une proposition de loi a été déposé en
ce sens les explications de marion
lefebvre abolir la prostitution
le débat est relancé par deux députés
danielle bousquet et guy geoffroy
veulent sa disparition totale
ils ont déposé une résolution
d'abolition de la prostitution
un texte très symbolique c'est pas une
activité volontaire une equipe qui
subissent et une activités violentes
c'est une activité qui installe qui
enracine ligue d'inégalité entre les
hommes et les femmes et c'est une
activité qui de surcroît est source de
toutes les violences et de tous les
traumatismes
mais aujourd'hui recourir à une
prostituée n'est pas interdit elle les
deux députés veulent donc déposé une
proposition de loi pour pénaliser les
clients stigmatiser ses clients et les
prostituées
c'est le risque de les pousser vers
encore plus de clandestinité et de
risques pour le strass le syndicat des
travailleurs du sexe
ils vont manifester cet après midi comme
la semaine dernière à quelques mètres
des députés les bains isoler encore plus
les jeunes femmes qui travaillent dans
des réseaux continuent et l'épidémie de
vih et des ist qui est complètement nié
actuellement en france en qui d'autre
que les travailleurs du sexe peuvent
parler de sexe aujourd'hui on est en
train de tomber dans une société
complètement pury tellement est tabou
les travailleurs du sexe réclament un
statut hommes et femmes
vingt mille personnes se prostitueraient
en france estime boutin on le voit bien
l'objectif c'est zéro prostitution c'est
tenable
c'est à 0 prostitution l'abolition c'est
parce que on des abolitionnistes et on
pense abolition 10 et 0 7 à 0
l'abolition de l'exclavage n'a pas
entraîné la suppression de l'expérience
malheureusement
mais c'est un objectif équipe moi je
suis absolument favorable avec cette
position après avoir hésité j'ai
réfléchi beaucoup pendant plus parce que
je ne connaissais pas bien sujet mais en
réalité aujourd'hui je pense qu'il n'ya
que cette posture qui est possible
pourquoi est en parfaite cohérence avec
notre pays pays des droits de l'homme
parce que le corps ne doit pas être
objet de commerce
ce n'est pas possible d'accepter que le
corps puisse être objet de commerce et
sur le plan philosophique
quand on voit certaines femmes qui
prétendent que c'est un travail comme un
autre
ces femmes là ne sont pas en général des
femmes qui sont sous la la puissance
d'un proxénète
elles sont elles sont libres ils font ce
qu'elles veulent mais la plupart des
prostituées saute en quoi sont-elles
escape cent des esclaves et donc ce
n'est pas tolérable dans un pays comme
la france donc l'objectif c'est
effectivement suis là et je note avec
joie que les quatre groupes de
l'assemblée nationale ont voté à
l'unanimité cette position qui est une
position nouvelle c'était pas si clair
que ça il ya quelques années en france
et du reste
j'ai été personnellement très choqué par
le délit de racolage qui avait été votée
dans les années 2000 vis-à-vis des
prostituées parce que les vraies
victimes ce sont quand même les
prostituées et les clients il faut les
condamner une sorte amende de 3750 euros
âmes ont bien sûr oui sur cette position
mais je ne veux pas de commerce du corps
je ne veux pas du commerce du corps donc
voilà des députés même de la droite
populaire 10,6 la pénalisation était la
solution sas aurait donc tout ça est
peut-être un peu virtuel non non c'est
pas du tout virtuel parce que c'est tout
un ensemble danser danser dans cette
résolution est dans la proposition de
loi qui je crois va être déposée cette
semaine dans les jours qui viennent
il ya tout un ensemble il ya bien sûr il
ya bien sûr les clients mais aussi à
l'accompagnement des femmes enfin c'est
vrai comment gère-t-on cet
accompagnement des femmes
les photos de ces vingt mille
prostituées qui ont été chiffrées en
france mais il n'est pas du tout
question en faisant l'abolition que les
abandonner bien au contraire c'est au
contraire de les accompagner il ya des
associations absolument merveilleuse moi
je me suis retrouvée elles ont ils ont
recoupé 37 associations et moi christine
boutin présidente du parti chrétien
démocrate
je me trouve associé
avec l'association pour le droit à
l'avortement voilà si vous voulez parce
que justement ça rassemble justement
tout
toutes les personnes qui ont un peu le
sens de la dignité la personne ça sont
toutes les contradictions de votre
personnage donc ces énoncés
mais j'ai pas contradiction je peux pas
vous laisser dire ça moi j'ai un fil
rouge qu'est la dignité de la personne
et je pense que le plus fragile doit
être protégé l'embryon on a tous été un
embryon et le fait que l'on relativise
la valeur de l'embryon fait
qu'aujourd'hui dans l'économie la
personne devient une variable
d'ajustement par rapport à des intérêts
fixés dès qu'on vous retrouve dans tout
ce qu'on voit absolument aller on va
passer au mercredi maintenant françois
auber aux candidats quelle surprise
françois bayrou troisième pour la
troisième fois le président du modem se
déclare candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
une annonce qui n'a surpris personne il
avait déjà présenté son programme la
semaine dernière selon un tempo qui lui
est personnelle bayrou candidat
l'homme est courtisé sur sa droite comme
sur sa gauche fabrice culine il se
présente en homme libre et pour
l'annoncé officielle de sa candidature
françois bayrou a ressorti la petite
musique qui l'avait amené à 18% au soir
du premier tour en 2007
ces priorités n'ont pas changé
production éducation et justice et face
à la crise il défend l'idée d'une
majorité très élargi en invitant tous
les réformateurs à le suivre
en 2007 on a été
très près de pouvoir gagner le deuxième
tour c'est à dire de pouvoir entre lui
et moi je trouve qu'il y as en 2012 plus
de raisons encore de choisir cette voie
nouvelle et donc plus d'attenté plus de
déception dans d'autres
candidature si les récents sondages ne
le créditent que de 7 à 9% des
intentions de vote
sa candidature intéresse ps et ump n'ont
pas attendu son officialisation pour lui
faire des appels du pied soutenu je le
dit françois bayrou est très clairement
au regard de sa propre pensée de ce
qu'il a fait par le passé
très clairement dans notre famille
politique je soir du premier tour tous
ceux qui voudront se tourner vers le
parti socialiste seront les bienvenus
autour du parti socialiste y compris
fonds s'avère aussi compris françois
daireaux contrairement à 2007 françois
bayrou prendra position pour un candidat
s'il n'atteint pas le second tour son
choix peut décider un électorat
centriste très convoité d'où ce jeu de
séduction mais le candidat du modem a
déjà prévenu ce soir il ne cédera rien à
françois hollande comme à nicolas
sarkozy alors françois bayrou candidat
incontournable
il faudra pour cela réussir un résultat
à deux chiffres au soir du premier tour
on a raconté la chance sera sûrement ses
500 parrainages lui françois bayroux
peut-il refaire le même coup qu'en 2007
c'est à dire faire un très bon score
autour de 18%
non ça je n'y crois pas mais je revenais
sur les parrainages il dit qu'il est un
homme libre
hélas combien de parlementaires s'il a
ses 500 signatures
qu'est-ce qu'il est tellement puisqu'il
est tellement courtisé à droite et à
gauche est il véritablement libre
françois bay au sila si la signature et
que je ne les ai pas il ya quelque chose
qui ne va pas voilà donc la liberté
c'est bien quand on l'a programmé il
faut mieux la vivre vraiment c'est à
dire et vous pensez qu'il va être tenu
un prêt par vous même vous dites il pas
voir mais il n'a pas de député il a plus
de députés
est-ce qu'il faut avoir des députés pour
voir ce signature des noms mais on sait
que l affluence des députés dans une
circonscription est importante et ça
peut débloquer des choses
bon donc en fait
si c'est fini il a un peu plus de chance
de les avoir parce qu'il a un peu plus
de députés mais monsieur bayrou n'a pas
de député il n'a pas voilà une île et il
est tout seul dans ce modem etc
donc je m'interroge et comme vous dites
vous-même observateurs politiques qu'il
est très courtisé à droite comme à
gauche
je pense que cet homme libre au rang des
signes est une grande puissance de
parrainage ce sont les maires mais oui
mais l'humeur mais je voulais
d'expliquer tout à l'heure les maires
ils sont maintenant en intercommunalités
et les intercommunalités sont présidées
par des gens qui sont engagés
politiquement en général dont
l'étiquette voilà c'est tout alors est
ce qu'il rassemble non je ne crois pas
qu'il aura son pourcentage avait le
crâne se dire c'est que à droite quand
on a ses 500 signatures aujourd'hui on
va devoir faire allégeance à l'elysée
derrière
en tous les cas si on les a aujourd'hui
c'est parce que les visés acceptent de
les donner
oui revenir un petit peu sur le cas de
françois bayrou notre viennent voir le
sujet et vous sûr que son coeur il ira à
droite françois bayrou face aux canes
faber france ou ailleurs vous savez
j'étais à l'udf avec lui je à l'époque
je les ai aidé dans mon aire d'influencé
devenir responsable de l'unef ou tu le
connaissais signe je connais très bien
un bon avec françois on peut s'attendre
à tout donc voilà il a exposé l'udf il a
fait il a tué le courant démocrate
chrétien que j'essaie de faire revivre
au parti chrétien démocrate
donc voilà tout et se pourrait qu'ils un
jour ils se disent pourquoi par françois
hollande ou nicolas sarkozy nicolas
sarkozy ça paraîtrait presque normal
lorsqu'on gouverner ensemble ils ont été
dans des gouvernements de droite
ensemble je pense que tout allait bien
quand ça serait différent je pense que
tout est possible le principal c'est que
les électeurs choisissent bien leur
candidat voilà pour savoir exactement où
il se situe vous le connaissez bien mais
vous n'avez pas l'air de l'apprécier
spécialement non parce que je
je respecte l'homme mais en tant que
responsable politique
il apporte l'énorme responsabilité
d'avoir fait exploser l'udf et d'avoir
tué en particulier le courant politique
que j'essaie de réanimer au parti
chrétien-démocrate que vous partagez
avec le monde
je pense qu'il est européen mais je suis
quand même très surprise qu'il était le
premier chantre a demandé à acheter
français
quand monsieur de villiers le disais il
ya dix ans il était le premier à taper
sur survilliers pour dire mais c'est un
lloris en est là il vient de service à
la belle france oui mais là à produire
et à acheter français mais il aurait
bien sûr mais tout mais c'est un leurre
c'est un leurre bien sûr qu'il faut
réindustrialiser notre pays et des
pme/pmi je le proposais avec différentes
actions très concrètes dans mon projet
mais aujourd'hui faire croire aux
français qu'on peut acheter purement
français c'est faux parce qu'il n'y a
plus de produits purement français donc
voilà mis à part les fresques que l'on
c'est une position pour l'élection
présidentielle sanaa ont même parlé dans
son discours qu'il a présentées dans
cette conférence de presse lundi secours
du parti communiste des années 46 après
guerre ecoutez jean sérien j'étais à
peine né chez pascal raconté le parti
communiste donc voilà achetez français
s'était enfin tous les cas c'est très
surprenant de la part d'anne d'un
européen comme il est je mets pas en
doute ceci qu'ils dansent à pour lancer
sa campagne franchement alors qu'il est
un homme expérimenté qu'on sait
parfaitement qu'il n'existe plus de pas
de produit pur français pur sucre
français dans notre production
autre sujet qui va vous intéresser jeudi
le sénat examine une proposition de loi
politiquement très sensible
accorder le droit de vote aux étrangers
aux élections locales cette proposition
de loi de la gauche majoritaire au sénat
a été voté tard dans la nuit une rude
bataille dans l'hémicycle entre la
gauche et la droite fait rare le premier
ministre est venu en personne défendre
nos positions du gouvernement à ce texte
le récit de jérôme rabier pour
l'adoption 173 contre 166 le sénat a
adopté l'ensemble de la proposition de
loi constitutionnelle
il est minuit jeudi soir et le sénat de
gauche adopte le texte autorisant le
droit de vote des étrangers aux
élections locales mais avant cela ce
sont plus de huit heures de débats
houleux qui ont marqué le texte françois
fillon en personne menant la contre
offensive
aucune des raisons avancées ne justifie
à mes yeux ce travail de sape d'un des
fondements de notre république
avec cette proposition la gauche
s'engage dans une voie dangereuse avec
légèreté
elle prend le risque de vider la
nationalité et la citoyenneté française
de leur substance une attaque en
introduction à une multitude
d'interventions la droite us de toutes
les procédures possibles pour bloquer le
texte sur les bancs claude guéant et
michel mercier
le gouvernement a envoyé ses ministres
en renfort ils se succèdent à la tribune
tous accuse le ps de coup politique et
de favoriser le communautarisme
le parti socialiste avec une régularité
d'horloge et depuis 1908 1880 1981
pardon opportunément est
systématiquement remet cette question à
l'ordre du jour à la veille de chaque
grande échéance électorale
à gauche on ré pic et on défend une
mesure symbole promise depuis 30 ans
mais que le sénat avait toujours refusé
d'examiner il était un devoir moral pour
nous par rapport à cet engagement moral
que d'inscrire ce texte nous le faisons
en vertu des principes des valeurs qui
sont les nôtres
l'affrontement dans l'hémicycle est
maintenant terminée mais le sujet
laissera des traces dans la perspective
des présidentielles
votre position que tim boutin faut-il
donner le droit de vote aux étrangers
aux élections locales
je pense que c'est une question qui
mérite d'être posée mais véritablement
la pause et en ce moment c'est de
l'irresponsabilité politique
non évidemment on voit très bien ce
texte n'a aucune chance d'être votée in
fine et le mettre en début de campagne
électorale présidentielle s'est
naturellement fait pour cliver et c'est
fait pour développer le front national
alors si véritablement le parti
socialiste joue la france à la roulette
pour donner un petit peu plus de place
au front national je laissais je les
estime irresponsable relationnel qui a
manifesté aux abords du sénat ce jeudi
ils ont invité marine le pen pour
fustiger et la droite et bien si la
gauche évidemment mais dans le fond
quand même sur l'inflation le fond moi
je l'écouté je trouve que les français
d'abord ne savent pas qu aujourd'hui
très peu savent que les fraudes que les
étrangers peuvent communautaires peuvent
voter sur notre territoire dont
certaines conditions aux élections
municipales sans état de joie ni les
grands comptes et les grands électeurs
jeu bon appui combien cette loi qui est
du reste pas suffisamment appliquée
parce que même il faut savoir que les
étrangers qui peuvent en bénéficier ne
l'utilisent pas suffisamment d'après les
derniers chiffres que j'ai pu avoir
c'est quelques centaines en fait un
petit millier peut-être que ça s'est
amélioré mais j'ai une dernier chiffre
que j'avais été 2008
donc je ne sais pas ce qu'est ce qu'il
ya depuis mais faisons appliquer cela la
crainte pour le vote des étrangers
c'est pas la peine de se cacher au tour
de son petit doigt c'est parce que les
français ont peur du vote des arabes des
musulmans
voilà mais ces personnes elles sont
intégrées dans notre pays elles paient
de l'impôt
je pense qu'il faudrait quand même se
poser la question pourquoi y at il une
discrimination je vois l'arjel en tous
les cas naturellement ça devrait être
envisagée que sur la base d'une
réciprocité et certainement pas dans une
période électorale dans une période
tellement troublés sur le plan
économique et européenne a peur c'est
celle du communautarisme selon françois
fillon un auto militarisme ou plutôt
intégration d'après vous c'est
remarquez c'est assez amusant de voir
qu'on parle de communautarisme alors que
depuis cinq ans je crois que ce serait
là le reproche majeur que je ferai au
président de la république c'est d'avoir
fait fragilisé notre cohésion sociale et
de nous avons mis les uns à côté des
autres sans sens sans avoir envie de
vivre ensemble s'avère actuellement 80%
des français
rendez vous compte 92 % des français
n'ont pas confiance dans leurs voisins
voilà où nous en sommes au bout de cinq
ans franchement ça me pose quelques
questions vous même vous êtes prononcé
pour la suppression du droit du sol
c'est pour nous en dire un petit peu
plus sûres sur ce sujet que vous me
posez dans votre bien est vrai il ya un
vrai sujet est bien vrai sujet en ce qui
concerne l'immigration en france
je pense que ça vient de deux raisons la
première c'est que nous n'avons pas
assumer notre histoire dans la
construction européenne en réaffirmant
dans le traité que notre histoire
c'était là et la bassine de judéo
chrétienne le fait de ne pas avoir
assumé cette histoire a laissé penser à
la fois aux habitants de l'europe et aux
autres que c'était un territoire en
jachère peur d'être envahi et tentative
d'invasion pour les autres donc il faut
clarifier les choses je demande à ce
qu'on remette le traité dans le traiter
les racines judéo chrétiennes et en ce
qui concerne le droit du sol j'ai
demandé à le supprimer parce que il faut
de la carte et pour devenir français
pour moi ça doit être le résultat d'une
démarche volontaire c'est aussi loin que
vous sur cette super c est parce qu il
faut une clarification se sont gênés ce
sont les propositions du front national
en elle madame le pen ne l'a pas repris
dans son projet et l'enel son père on a
parlé il ya quelques années mais elle ne
l'a pas repris je suis la seule à
l'avoir pris et je me positionne pas
vis-à-vis du front national mon objectif
c'est de rétablir la cohésion entre nous
et pour rétablir cette cohésion il faut
simplifier il faut rendre transparente
il faut comprendre les règles du jeu et
devenir français c'est quelque chose qui
s'acquiert et pour que ça puisse
s'aguerrir et bien il faut pas le droit
du sol parce que si par hasard vous êtes
né sur ce territoire goudin les français
vous n'avez pas fait l'effort et
peut-être qu'eux mêmes
on peut très bien comprendre que des
personnes et la nationalité française il
n'en ai pas envie
on va pardon excusez moi je vous coupe
on va parler d'une autre proposition de
loi
vous voulez bien examiné par le sénat
encore ce jeudi et adopté par
l'assemblée sur le contrôle des armes à
feu ce texte vise notamment à renforcer
la répression du trafic
que peuvent faire les policiers face à
la recrudescence des armes de guerre le
chef de l'état en visite à marseille où
un policier a trouvé la mort promet des
fusils à pompe pour faire face à la
nouvelle criminalité
mounir souci fusil à pompe contre
kalachnikov
les policiers marseillais qui
réclamaient plus de moyens pour lutter
contre les délinquants conscient armés
ont été entendus des fusils à pompes
supplémentaires seront distribués aux
brigades anticriminalité des bouches du
rhône d'ici à la fin de l'année cette
mesure devrait être étendue aux autres
bacs en 2012
en tout 150 de ces armes et qui prend
les brigades de la police nationale
parallèlement le sénat a adopté à
l'unanimité une proposition de loi qui
accentue et simplifie le contrôle des
armes
là tout le volet pénal de la loi qui
renforce également
notre réglementation par rapport
justement aux trafiquants et aux
détenteurs illégaux d'armes dans notre
pays mais pour endiguer le trafic
d'armes
la loi ne suffit pas il s'agit de mettre
en place un dispositif par le biais des
forces de police qui puisse permettre de
démanteler les gangs organisés et dente
rome pour de faire en sorte d'
interrompre de manière beaucoup plus
conséquente
l'entrée de ces armes sur le sol
français principalement à porter des
balkans une kalachnikov se négocie pour
3000 euros la circulation des armes de
guerre se banalise depuis le début de
l'année 3355 ont été saisis sur le
territoire christine boutin de fusil à
pompe pour les policiers c'est une
solution et pour quel type
d'intervention je pense que c'est une
surenchère moi je comprends très bien
qu'il faille protéger les policiers mais
c'était terrible je trouve que c'est ça
signifie l'échec de notre société de ce
que nous avons construit en réalité nous
avons des problèmes d'économie
nous avons des problèmes de violence
mais c'est aussi parce que nous avons
perdu un certain nombre de nos repères
et qu'il faut redonner du sens à nos
vies
il faut redonner du sens collectif à
notre société
c'est pas en rachetant encore des armes
à feu les autres vont en acheter
d'autres et et on va finir par tous se
tirer dessus
je disais 80 % des français n'ont pas
confiance dans leurs voisins on va
terminer cette émission c'est avec ces
images jeudi soir devant le théâtre du
rond point à paris
cent soixante personnes venues protester
contre la pièce golgota picnic spectacle
autour de la figure du christ
manifestation qui s'est passé sans
incident majeur
beaucoup plus calmement en tout cas qu'à
toulouse il y a quelques semaines ou des
ultra catholique avait créé des
incidents christine boutin il y avait
une baisse également à paris vous êtes
un rayer une veillée exactement à notre
dame à paris vous êtes allé hier mais
vous avez pris quand même vos distances
avec ces manifestations souvent de la
part des intégristes
je comprends que d'abord je suis contre
la censure
je pense que la liberté d'expression est
un trésor et il ne faut jamais l'abîmé
donc voilà l'expression théâtrale je
comprends qu'elle ait pu choquer un
certain nombre de catholiques et
peut-être moi si j'avais vu cette pièce
de théâtre je comprends qu'elles
puissent être baissé mais le problème
c'est que lorsque l'on est catholique
notre religion est une religion de
l'amour notre religion est une religion
de la paix jamais la réponse pour moi ne
peut être donnée par rapport une
blessure que je pourrait subir par une
attitude de violence oreillers de
violence dans la précédente à toute
manifestation et à toulouse en alu pour
moi ce n'est pas possible
le christ auquel je crois et c'est
l'amour c'est c'est pas possible nous ne
pouvons pas faire comme ça et c'est dur
est magnifique et que le cardinal
vingt-trois est proposé ce qui est
véritablement dans notre tradition et
notre notre foi c'est à dire la prière
nous avons une veillée de méditation sur
sur la crucifixion du christ qui était
superbe qui était très belle y avait
4000 personnes
donc voilà je pense que c'est important
aussi qu'on en fasse comprendre que les
catholiques ne sont pas des extrémistes
et il ne sommes pas voilà alors les
extrémistes dans ce pays laïc c'est pas
difficile pour un politique de mettre en
avant sa foi mais l'article 1 de la
constitution française qu'est ce qu'il
nous dit qu'est ce qu'il me dit la
france est une république laïque
indivisible qui respecte toutes les
croyances et toutes les religions
donc voilà on reste avec eux mais quand
on est une femme ou un homme politique
engagé qu'on est candidat à l'élection
présidentielle à transparence vis-à-vis
de ses électeurs
moi mes électeurs savaient très bien que
j'étais catholique
je n'impose personnes à devenir
catholique je respecte les musulmans
comme je respecte les francs maçons
comme je respecte les agnostiques
mais moi je suis ce que je suis et
j'essaie d'être ce que je suis voilà
c'est ça c'est l'application de
l'article 1 de la constitution respect
de toutes les croyances et toutes les
religions vous quitte donc aller à cette
semaine ce jeudi soit est ce que vous
pensez qu'il y à un climat de
christianophobie en france parce que je
suis très engagé sur le plan religieux
tout le monde le sait que j'assume ma
foi j'ai aussi beaucoup de relève
sion avec les musulmans et avec les
juifs bien figurez vous qu effectivement
les chrétiens nous avons un sentiment d
fessia nos phobies
mais c'est également partagé chez les
musulmans qui ont l'impression de muse
de d'islamophobie et des juifs qu'ils
avaient exactement la même position
donc aujourd'hui on voit très bien qu'on
est à la croisée des chemins en france
par rapport au regard que l'on porte sur
la religion
on nous ne sommes pas mature en france
vis-à-vis du fait religieux n'y a que
dans notre pays où nous avons tellement
de difficultés il suffit d'aller à
l'étranger pour voir que ça se passe
beaucoup mieux
ce n'est pas que les chrétiens les
catholiques qui ont ce sentiment là en
france
voilà c'est pas plutôt empreinte de
désinfection ville à la religion
catholique qui n'ont non j'avais des
problèmes de l'église française a je
crois pas du tout je crois pas du tout
parce qu'en fait quand on parle de
christianophobie ce sont les hommes et
les femmes chrétiens qui le ressentent
ce n'est pas l'église qui l'ont scellé
les hommes et les femmes
et quand vous parlez aux musulmans c'est
aussi vis-à-vis de l'islam
c'est dans leur chair qu'ils ont
l'impression d'être jetés et ils n'ont
peut-être pas complètement tort que je
le vois vous parliez de l'art en général
et que j'étais évidemment contre la
censure
cette caisse vous ne l'avez pas vu l'un
mais en quoi aujourd'hui on peut dire
qu'une pièce est blasphématoire et que
l'arrêt de la somme à toi un peu
philosophique mais l'annoncé par être
philosophique du tout il n'y a pas de la
semaine en france donc c'est pas
impossible d'attaquer sur la base du
prénom c'est ce qu'on entend de nos
manifestations
mais je vous ai dis moi ce que j'en
pensais je pense qu'il ya pas le
blasphème n'existe pas en france en
terme de droit par contre qu'il y ait
des blessures
en tant que catholique vis-à-vis d'une
expression théâtrale
oui je la comprends alors le problème
est de savoir par rapport à cette
blessure comment on réagit est-ce qu'on
réagit je pense que le fait qu'il eut
quatre mille personnes plus de 4000
personnes à notre dame est un est un
événement beaucoup plus important il
était dans l'appel recueillement la
prière beaucoup plus important sur
l'affirmation de notre foi que des
attitudes de plus plus bruyante 1
christine boutin c'est sur ces mots que
nous allons nous quitte et merci d'avoir
rêvé avec nous pendant cette toute
petite heure quant à nous on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine merci beaucoup